ja ich setze mich mit dem thema
inklusion schon allein deshalb ausländer
weil ich selber das tourette-syndrom
habe und es ist für mich einfach sehr
wichtig dass man noch viel mehr inklusiv
handeln dass man menschen die eine
besondere besonderheit an den tag legen
aber auch inkludiert in die mitte der
gesellschaft takt und da gab es eben
jetzt neuen fall auf den bin ich
aufmerksam geworden ein kind einer
autismus spektrum störungen eines
schulausflugs verwiesen wurde weil es zu
kompliziert waren da sind wir natürlich
auch gleich wieder so die ja an sich
alles
bewegt und ich war einfach auf 180 das
ist so mein mann meine aufreger der
woche quasi auch
genug passiert denn sowas häufiger in
deutschland sie selbstsicher stark damit
außen genau aber ist das 1 1 zum
beispiel oder haben sie das gefühl dass
die politik bei der inklusion versager
ich glaube also nicht nur die politik
sondern auch die umsetzung ist ultra
schwer und ich glaube oftmals wird wird
wird das auch mit einem guten gefühl
versucht also ich will den leuten nicht
absprechen dass sie da nicht große und
gute intention haben aber es scheitert
irgendwie so am alltag noch mal täglich
also ich selbst habe eine story in einer
ganz normalen schule gewesen die aber
auch durch aus meiner klasse gab es
durchaus menschen die auch adhs hatten
oder gab es jemand mit irgendeiner
knochen störungen und hast also die die
kann man im rollstuhl das war aber auch
völlig normal das ist einfach passiert
wir waren einfach alle da wollen alle
gleich behandelt und ich bin sehr
dankbar dafür dass ich dann so in der
schule war und würde es mir einfach
wünschen dass es das noch viel mehr gibt
und wenn ich so was halt höher dass
jemand sagt ja sie sind also das kind
ist jetzt ein ausgeschlossen worden das
war und ist jetzt einfach so am besten
so weil das hätte wahrscheinlich die
lehrkräfte überfordert oder so dann
kriege ich eine krawatte weil ich
einfach denke da muss doch was machbar
sein da muss doch einfach auch so ein
kind ermöglicht werden dass es an diesem
schulausflug teilnehmen zum beispiel
also das ist es mir auffällt wenn ich so
ehrlich sein darf wenn ich
beispielsweise im restaurant
und natürlich sind sie anders als wie
ich mich jetzt verhalten sollte man am
besten damit umgehen als mensch als ganz
ganz wichtig ich glaube dass schon das
überschneidet sich jetzt auch wieder mit
dem was sie wollen gesagt haben
augenhöhe augenhöhe ist das a und o dass
man sich wirklich natürlich sind es
besonderheit natürlich gucke ich auch
wenn ich irgendjemanden sehen er
stottert und davon mehr als jemand der
der irgendwie sich seltsam bewegt aber
das wichtige ist dass man wieder dieses
über beschützende hat so nach dem motto
darf ich ihm die tür aufmachen sie
kriegen ja gar nichts mehr auf die reihe
und
als auch nicht natürlich diese andere
geschichte hat dass man irgend jemand
runter punkt wo du reißt dich mal
zusammen das ist
wirklich ganz normal sind die limes
zeitpunkt einfach mal ignorieren und
vielleicht auch mal drüber lachen aber
die menschen einfach so behandeln wie
man selber behandelt werden das ist also
das fehlt mir einfach ganz ganz oft auf
wenn ich das sagen darf es ist natürlich
viel unsicherheit angst ja
der klassiker wo der vater oder die
mutter dann das kind weg sie guckt da
nicht immer so hin klingt ganz
natürlicher weise genau und damit hätte
das kind und das wird wahrscheinlich
geworden keine überhaupt memory kinder
kommen und fragen und ich erkläre es
dann auch wissen es dann irgendwie ging
direkt zu erzählen und zu erklären man
mir das damals ich hatte eine
hautentzündung es ist eine spätfolge der
inhalt ohhh red ja auch die genetische
komponente hat aber die hat es so ich
mich informiert hatte gepusht wollen das
ganze und ich sag das dann immer ich
hatte so eine erkrankung am kopf und so
weiter ich kann das nicht kontrollieren
die kinder sind total zufrieden damit
die gucken dann nicht mehr und das ding
ist nämlich es geht jetzt minute oder
den augen ist von meiner genau und wenn
ich das so sagen darf ich glaube da ist
es auch eine schöne schere zu sehen
zwischen den vielen papieren die
erstellt werden diskussionen gesetze und
noch eine andere gremien die gebildet
werden die sitzen alle an schönen
tischen zusammen und machen tolle
konzepte und den fordern natürlich auch
geld für irgendwelche projekte 1 ich
glaube darum geht es nicht ich mir fällt
immer verzeihen wenn sie ja sagen darauf
meine meine großmutter schon lange
verstorben ein die hat so viel gutes im
leben getan hat nie darüber geredet die
war nie einer sitzung die hat das nie
auf sein war ihr macht die hat das
einfach gemacht er hat gesehen dass da
irgendwas nötig dann hat es getan das
ist und ich glaube das haben früher
menschen häufiger geht also jetzt jetzt
wollen wir alles in gesetze gießen und
verordnungen gießen wir fragen erst mal
wo ist der etat für dieses und jenes
nein wir brauchen nicht wir müssen
einfach natürlich auch klassen und
gruppen in ganz kleinen gruppen machen
so wie sie wenn sie sagen wir kindern da
haben sie nehmen haben sie die beste
möglichkeit dann mit denen er war es
denn gerade weil ich das erlebe die
leicht dass man gehen kann so denke ich
warum macht man es sich einfach machen
nicht mehr leute so was und warum tut
man da nicht dementsprechend natürlich
lehrerpersonal usw das ist alles und
abgesetzt und die leute sagt wir jetzt
entschuldigen da fehlen dann auch
erziehungsberatung und so weiter leute
die dabei das ja vielleicht einmal nach
dem kind guckt und sich mit dem die
klasse geht es ist alles zusammen das
muss man alles beantragen aber es dinge
so vieles mehr einfach und mich waren
sie erst sich dann erkranken oder die
renault im rat und die diagnose habe ich
mit 15 bekommen also quasi sechs jahre
mit neun fing das schon an genau was er
denn in stellung gehen sie denn den
schulen tatsächlich gegen schumann
sondern auch die aufklärungsrate quasi
innerhalb für das fsj also die leute
diese zwei sozialen jahr absolvieren
dann in die pflegeberufe gehen um die
einfach da auch ein bisschen feiern
nächstes ganze zeit durch den kopf
gegangen eigentlich wir wollen wir das
thema ko runde nicht groß aber im
prinzip haben in den letzten zwei jahren
das ja auch gesehen corona deckt auf
also was damit kindern passiert ist und
jugendlichen passiert ist die nicht
geimpft oder die ein bisschen kritisch
die sachen gesehen haben also da ist
wahrlich was passiert ist das heißt da
ist schon bodensatz an problematik darin
der gesehen haben ja schon der vorteil
schon davor da und und lange schon davor
also das heißt es ist jetzt nicht so
dass wir es mit einem aktuellen problem
haben sondern das ist ein ding was da
offensichtlich immer noch da ist und es
ist ein großes gesellschaftliches
problem es geht
also ich denke das was die oma da hat
und die aus einer zeit kommt die die
offensichtlich noch nicht so
entmenschlicht und dämonisiert und und
neoliberal diese technokratie siert und
mechanistisch ist da hat sich viel getan
den letzten jahrzehnten also das ist
nicht gut geworden und und die
stresserkrankungen hat zugenommen die
angst erkannt haben zugenommen die
soziale isolation hat zugenommen in den
letzten
richtig
und auch alles normalisieren werden ist
normal dass alles perfekt sein die
perfekt imitierten maschinen das sind
wir alle
normale und zum genießen das geht zum
glück richtig und ich denke das ist
etwas da können wir ja ja und wir können
aus der krise lernen man noch mal es ist
in einem unglaublichem ausmaß passiert
was hier ein beispiel ist das ist zuhauf
passiert wo man sich wirklich denkt wer
sind diese lehre wer sind diese menschen
die kinder die
sich nicht impfen lassen umgedreht an
der andaman stehen lassen ja also das
sind sachen ich kann ihnen sachen
erzählen ich habe das alles gesammelt
werden von kritischen pädagogen in
österreich da habe ich listen an
beispielen das ist eine katastrophe eine
menschliche katastrophe
und ja auch einiges zugestimmt aber noch
gerne einmal genau bei ihnen bleiben
wenn ja wie das denn erlebt in ihrer
schulzeit in ihrer jugend auch dass sie
gesagt habe hätten lehrer besser
geschult auf jeden fall definitiv als
ich hatte es war witzigerweise immer so
dass das es so 2 als auch später auf den
weiterführenden schulen das ist man so
zwei drei lehrer gehabt die top waren
die wirklich möglich vom herzen her ich
habe ja gar nicht geschult waren es war
einfach so eine empathie über ein
einfach die haben intuitiv richtig
gehandelt und es gab auch immer drei
vier leute die wo ich gedacht habe ich
dreh komplett durch also habe ich raus
geschickt die habe ich ja mal die ich
muss irgendwie strafarbeiten machen weil
es einfach ein arzt so wahrgenommen
wurde also da wurde überhaupt nicht mal
nachgefragt ist es vielleicht irgendwas
hast du nicht kontrollieren kannst oder
mobbing kontrollieren kann das war
einfach gleich ja der der macht das mit
absicht er will aufmerksamkeit
generieren und so natürlich also als ob
ich mir nichts schöneres vorstellen den
kopf zu hauen und die ganzen tag und so
zu schützen
was kann die politik tun oder was tun ja
ich möchte an das anknüpfen was der
doktor specht sagte es gibt viel auf dem
papier viel theoretisch aber es ist
einfach noch viel zu wenig was in der
realität in den klassenräumen ankommt
hier in berlin in der landespolitik da
wird das auf dem papier auch sehr hoch
gehoben inklusion was richtig ich bin
sehr froh dass sie heute das thema
mitgebracht weil es einfach ich fand
dass jetzt auch ein bisschen negativ
resigniert haben sind ja so viele
chancen und potenziale die in den
menschen ruhen und die man gar nicht
wertschätzt und die selbstbestimmung gar
nicht mehr möglich wenn man sich nicht
bemüht hier
ja zu inkludieren und auch eben leute zu
haben die ihr helfen können und das ist
eben der entscheidende punkt wo man dann
doch wieder ein bisschen geld
finanzen und organisationen fachkräfte
braucht und sich da auch ehrlich machen
muss und nicht sagen muss wir haben hier
das ziel jede schule soll inclusive
seien aber daneben mich das personal
an der seite ist studieren auch grenzen
nein das glaube ich nicht ich glaube die
politik und die gesellschaft ist
gefordert noch viel stärker hürden und
grenzen wegzuräumen aber das müssen
menschen ja auch leisten können im
alltag und eben junge menschen begleiten
kann ginge und ich bin auch großer fan
davon zu sagen nicht für alle menschen
gibt es die eine lösung es gibt ganz
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten der und
inklusion und manche eltern wünschen
sich auch eine schule vielleicht mit
besonderem förderbedarf andere sagen es
ist der regelunterricht und für alles
muss es eine gute ausstattung geben und
hier in berlin kann ich nur sagen rot
grün rot hat das in jedem zweiten trakt
drin in der bildungspolitischen
inklusion auf dem papier aber es ist
nicht in den klassenräumen genau und es
muss sich auch von der infrastruktur für
den fachkräften ja dringend noch was
dann vielleicht sollten wir da wirklich
was gesagt hat war eine größe in ein ich
würde auch sagen dramatisch einfach tun
er praktisch geneigt das ist also dann
auch noch hinterher schicken will weil
ich das auch so ein bisschen dieses
dieses ein bisschen dieses solchen
ausdrücken ein bisschen auch diese
heuchelei weglassen das ist manchmal ist
aufgefallen dass ich war auf einer vor
einigen jahren auf dem
fest kann man sagen so eine art festival
und das land das toleranz tagen und es
war wirklich also schon mal ein das hat
mich dann so angesprochen natürlich
dahin gegangen und da waren dann also
viele künstler die irgendwie handicap
hatten oder migrationshintergrund da
wollte man einfach so ein großes buntes
potpourri zeigen und allem den raum
geben und ich war als dass dort auch und
hab dann mitbekommen die zwei sich
unterhalten neben mir und dann bist du
bald auch wieder bei dem toleranz tagen
leipzig achtköpfigen sie angestoßen sekt
und als ich ein thema haben sie mich
angeguckt also sie mich am liebsten
gleich aus
das passt irgendwie also ich gehe nicht
hin um das zu propagieren sondern man
sollte das auch mal erleben man sollte
das selber mehr leben und vielleicht
einfach mehr machen und weniger ja nur
zuschauen